bienvenidos de vuelta cuando dejamos el
último vídeo quedó pendiente un detalle
verdad y queríamos encontrar el ángulo
que tenía este vector velocidad de la
pelota vez después del choque así que
vamos a repasar brevemente lo que
hicimos para poder continuar y resolver
este problema del ángulo primero lo que
teníamos que notar es que este problema
era esencialmente un problema de
conservación del momento y decíamos que
el momento se conserva en varias
direcciones cuando se conserva en cada
una de las componentes del movimiento
por ejemplo aquí tenemos dos dos
dimensiones así que si se tiene que
conservar el momento en la dirección
horizontal y en la dirección vertical
así que todo el momento inicial provenía
de esta pelota que llevaba digamos una
velocidad de tres metros sobre segundo
golpeaba la pelota ve que se que y más
bien la pelota rebotaba en esta
dirección verdad a 30 grados del su
movimiento original y con una velocidad
de 2 metros por segundo entonces el
momento que llevaba la pelota
a la masa por la velocidad que son 10 x
30 en la dirección horizontal y no
llevaba momento digamos en la dirección
vertical pues justamente porque solo se
mueve en la dirección horizontal y
después al golpear la pelota
teníamos que descomponer el vector
velocidad este este amarillo que estoy
señalando los descomponemos en cada una
de sus componentes verdad de estas dos
velocidades y finalmente podríamos
calcular el momento que llevaba la
pelota en cada una de las direcciones
verdad por ejemplo el momento que
llevaba en la dirección que era la masa
por la velocidad que son diez por uno y
así podríamos despejar cuál era el
momento de la pelota ve que debe llevar
y concluimos que era menos 10 kilogramos
metros sobre segundo ahora el momento es
masa por velocidad y la masa valía 5 y
podríamos de esta forma despejar la
velocidad de forma similar podríamos
calcular la velocidad en la dirección x
verdad en la dirección horizontal
ahora si queremos describir la velocidad
debe de la misma forma que hay eso es lo
que vamos a hacer en este vídeo tenemos
que encontrar el tamaño de este vector y
el ángulo que tiene con respecto al
movimiento horizontal que llevaba la
pelota a inicialmente así que para
lograrlo tenemos que usar trigonometría
básica y directa muy bien así que vamos
a hacerlo un poquito más abajo digamos
nosotros tenemos muy bien quién es algo
más bien sabemos quién era este vector y
quién era el que es la componente esta
es la componente de la velocidad debe en
la dirección x y esto era 2.54 metros
sobre segundo
aquí tenemos 2.54 metros sobre segundo y
la componente vertical que de hecho va
hacia abajo
ahí lo tienen digamos era la velocidad
de ve en la componente vertical era si
no mal recuerdo dos metros sobre segundo
menos dos metros sobre segundo vamos a
ponerlo así sólo como dos metros sobre
segundo hacia abajo
muy bien
ahora nosotros queremos encontrar
realmente este vector que es la suma de
estos dos a estas alturas quizás ya de
las que ya debes estar muy relacionado
con cómo es la suma de vectores
pero este es el vector que nos interesa
verdad y veamos que lo que tenemos que
calcular también es este ángulo de aquí
este ángulo también nos determina este
vector así que todo este todo este este
diagrama que estamos pintando es
correspondiente para la pelota de así
que el primer detalle es muy sencillo
calcular el tamaño de este vector y eso
simplemente lo podemos hacer porque
tenemos un triángulo rectángulo y
podemos utilizar el teorema de pitágoras
así que el tamaño de este vector es la
raíz cuadrada de la suma de los
cuadrados de los catetos
es decir 2.54 al cuadrado más 2 al
cuadrado y esto quién es pues no sé
vamos a sacar la calculadora vamos a
poner 2.54 al cuadrado y eso es
6.45 16 vamos a dejarlo como 6.45 aquí
entonces es la raíz cuadrada de 6.45 + 2
al cuadrado que es 4 y esto es 6.45 4
nos da 10.45 y ahora hay que calcular la
raíz cuadrada de 10.45 10.45 sacamos
raíz cuadrada y eso nos da más o menos
algo así como 3.2
vamos a dejarlo como 3.2 muy bien así
que este vector tiene una veloz o una
rapidez de 3.2 metros sobre segundo
ahora lo único que nos falta es calcular
el ángulo y pues podemos utilizar
cualquier función trigonométricas porque
tenemos los tres lados de este triángulo
no se vamos a utilizar por ejemplo el
seno del ángulo el seno del ángulo pues
es cateto opuesto
hipotenusa el cateto opuesto mide 2
mientras que la hipotenusa mide 3.2 muy
bien así que si hacen la división
2 / 3 puntos 2 eso nos da 0.6 25 así que
esto es 0.6 25 como calculamos el ángulo
bueno aquí hay que utilizar algo que
decimos que es bueno que se conoce como
el arco seno es decir que el ángulo teta
es el arco seno de no es de 0.6 25 a lo
mejor no está muy relacionado con qué es
el arco seno a lo mejor ya has visto los
vídeos de funciones trigonométricas
inversas pero esencialmente el arco seno
nos dice cuál es el ángulo cuyo seno nos
da 0.6 25 verdad así que eso nosotros no
tenemos una forma práctica de conocerlo
necesitamos hacerlo con la calculadora
aquí ponemos las inversas
tenemos
0.6 25 y vamos a calcular el seno
inverso o el arco sen así que esto nos
da 38 puntos 7 vamos a ponerlo así estos
son 38 puntos 7 grados muy bien entonces
ya tenemos quién es este ángulo este
ángulo es 38.7 grados así que todo esto
tiene mucho sentido verdad nuestro
nuestra bola ve se empieza a mover en
esta dirección y si nos damos cuenta
podemos comparar que la componente
vertical de la dirección que debe es 2
pero hacia abajo mientras que la
componente vertical de la pelota es 1 y
eso se puede explicar fácilmente porque
la masa debe es la mitad de la masa de a
muy bien ahora tú dirás por qué eso no
ocurre en la dirección horizontal bueno
eso es porque el ángulo está afectando
verdad el ángulo con él
rebotaron está afectando el tamaño de
cada uno de cada una de las componentes
horizontales entonces yo espero que para
ti tenga bastante sentido ya que es
esencialmente ve la pelota ve va a ir
más rápido fíjate que va a 3.2 metros
sobre segundo mientras que iba a dos
pero esencialmente como la masa debe es
menor necesitamos que la pelota de que
la pelota sea más rápida verdad y ya
vimos más o menos cómo se relacionan las
componentes horizontales y verticales
pero bueno eso sería todo para este
ejercicio nos vemos en los próximos
vídeos